this video will make more sense if
you've watched part 1 of this series
where I explain the ending because now
that we know what it means to sit upon
the throne we can explore the stories of
those who would sit upon it and it turns
out the original king of drangleic
vendrick was supposed to link the flame
and sit the throne but he never did and
when you acquire his soul it is a soul
of he who would link the flame Queen
nashandra also makes reference to this
when you visit her in the throne room
the last king of this land King vendrick
as he was called he was less of a king
and you might imagine he found the
strength to rule his people and when the
undead were born cursed he found more
strength to face them but in the end he
never took the true throne a true
monarch is much more than a ruler of men
a true monarch carries the weight of
their souls if a true monarch must carry
a huge weight of souls and incinerate
himself in the kiln to link the fire
then perhaps vendrick wanted none of it
so now we go back back before there was
a king a queen and back before
vendrick's kingdom of drangleic was even
founded many kingdoms have risen and
fallen on the spot that is now called
drangleic the kingdoms take different
shapes but the framework is always the
same there's always a king there is
always the undead curse and there are
always four powerful souls back in Dark
Souls 1 there were four great ones it's
likely these were the first four great
ones as they found their souls within
the first flame many kingdoms have risen
and fallen on this very spot each like a
great flame that turns to soot King
vendrick founded drangleic he vanquished
four great ones
and built this kingdom upon their souls
vendrick crushed the kingdom and the
four great ones who existed before him
he then instigated a powerful Kingdom
named drangleic which came about due to
those who fought for him the ring
bearing the soldiers seal was granted to
warriors who distinguished themselves in
the service of King vendrick he also
commanded the Dragon Riders elite
Knights straddling dragons who helped
him crush the kingdoms former
inhabitants drangleic was built upon the
graves of those they defeated and his
kingdom prospered but vendrick wasn't
just interested in gaining the throne he
also sought to maintain it and then
there was a queen the King had a dear
queen a woman of unparalleled beauty
long ago the Queen came to us alone from
a faraway land she warned our Lord of
the looming threat across the seas of
the Giants the King crossed the ocean
and defeated the Giants with the Queen
at his side the King commandeered their
power and created the golems with the
golems the king created this castle to
celebrate victory and to show his love
his gratitude to his queen the Queen
brought peace to this land and to her
King a piece of deep
it was like the dark is this some sort
of a dream where am i what has happened
to our castle
long ago the king cross the Seas
pillaged the land of giants and brought
back a prize it was then that the golems
materialized whatever vendrick stole it
appears to have come with the ability to
create automatons in the form of golems
golems are inanimate beings that carry
out a set purpose like opening a door or
building a bridge this purpose is
powered by souls so it seems as if the
thing vendrick stole from the Giants
allowed him to infuse things with Souls
key to many advancements was the Kings
elder brother aldea aldea helped found
drangleic and he was known for his
experiments the mysterious lord aldia
secluded himself inside a manor to
conduct various experiments those who
visited the manor disappeared replaced
over time with malformed beasts that
roamed its halls his discarded
experiments are seen throughout the
entire land of drangleic and i believe
that when the kingdom encountered
trouble vendrick turned to his brother
for an experiment that might just solve
his problem after conquering the Giants
drangleic knew peace for a time this
peace was destined to be short-lived for
the undead curse had begun to appear in
drangleic vendrick was trying to find
ways to fight the curse many of his
actions and the structures and creations
within the land seemed bent towards this
end like the rulers of Lordran before
him Bendrick was frightened by the curse
and unlike the lords in Lordran vendrick
was human and susceptible to the curse
just like his subjects were the origins
of the curse is becoming known to us the
common trend between the two games is
that the curse appears when the flame is
fading but vendrick doesn't know this
like the lords in Lordran before him
vendrick assumed that the curse was
almost like an infection and he condemns
the undead imprisoning and exile
the Huntsman's corpse is evidence of
this mindset undead hunts took place
here before vendrick's time and these
were led by the old iron king undead
were corralled and locked away but this
solved nothing also the skeleton Lords
were once charged with the capture of
all undead but even they were overcome
by the curse and lastly the
executioner's chariot was created only
to torment undead running endlessly in a
loop and running the undead down over
and over and regardless of all this not
working when king vendrick became ruler
of drangleic he took similar measures to
the rulers before him long ago the
dungeons overflowed with the accursed
and the king commanded a contorted
sentry to deliver those with no cells to
a faraway land to make certain that they
were never heard from again we all
fought the flexile sentry who waits in a
boat outside no-man's Wharf when the
bell is rung it signals that a new
shipment has arrived and the flexile
sentry comes in to take them away the
King also hired shadow men to put down
the Hallows but before long they will
hollowed themselves and we see the
pursuer which is a being without much
backstory other than his purpose to hunt
down bearers of the curse and cut them
down during all this vendrick's time was
running out a powerful soul is like a
curse and vendrick king of drangleic
used a powerful soul to keep the curse
at bay sölden tells us that the curse is
traceable to the soul if the soul is the
essence of life itself
then the real curse must be to walk this
very earth vendrick is commonly touted
as one who peered straight into the
essence of the soul presumably in an
attempt to understand this curse
vendrick and his brother aldia began
trying to discover the secrets of life
itself
the malformed claws tell us this saying
that aldea viewed the undead as key to
this mystery at some point I think it's
likely that they stumbled upon something
that we know but they didn't that the
curse of the undead seems to be tied to
the fading flame that previous Kingdom
saw the undead curse appear when the
first flame faded or that a cycle was
taking place where kingdoms were rising
into an age of fire and falling into an
age of dark that there was almost some
sort of fate involved from item
descriptions and from Al Diaz creations
we can see that vendrick and Al do a try
to find a way to cheat fate it looks
like they were trying to find a way to
preserve their kingdom so that fate
would not recycle their kingdom just
like all the others but how do you cheat
fate the seed of a tree of giants tells
us that death is not the end for
anything that has ever once lived
remains a part of a great cycle of
regeneration but what of those outside
the cycle the only things outside the
cycle of death and rebirth are those
that never lived at all the ancient
dragons aldia kept giants in his Manor
and attempted to recreate a dragon but
after some time he was not heard from
again we find the ancient dragon at the
peak of the dragon Airy it's really
peculiar being as it drops a giant soul
upon death along with dragon bones it's
almost as if
aldia used a giant soul to construct
such a being we know that after vendrick
invaded the Giants he came back with the
ability to construct golems he could
also infuse Souls into inanimate objects
what if aldea tried to reanimate an
ancient dragon in the same manner the
powerful soul would give life to the
inanimate bones just like regular Souls
give life to the golems you'll find a
great creature far to the east a
colossal thing with the strength to
match its size or something playing the
part at least brave undead what did that
dragon tell you
that thing is a problem false deity
don't be fooled my undead it's possible
considering all this that aldea thought
that by reviving the ancient dragon he
could revive a being that was outside
the shackles of fate the ancient dragons
of Dark Souls ones were outside the
cycle of fire and dark living in a
lifeless age of gray he went further
than this though when you consider the
dialogue of Shanna wat the Emerald
Herald my name is Shanna
the dragon gave me this name for I was
born with a nun I was born of dragons
contrived by name born of dragons
contrived by men it looks as if aldea
attempted to birth another fire keeper a
melding of human and dragon in the form
of Shan alot the Emerald Herald one who
could break the shackles of fate itself
and maintain the fires indefinitely they
say that she is the last fire keeper but
they say a lot of things but they fail I
did not come out as intending fate would
not be best and men were cursed once
again at some point during all this the
Giants must have rallied and invaded
drangleic with a vengeance this battle
spans multiple generations bringing
drangleic to ruin my father and his
father both fought the Giants on this
very land
soon the Giants will descend upon this
fort it is revenge for the kingdom's
misguided barbarism my blade may break
my arrows for wide but my will shall
never be broken in the midst of this
invasion I think that King vendrick had
a chilling realization vendrick's
attempt to create the Emerald Herald
tells us that he understands a cycle is
taking place a cycle where kingdoms are
born into an age of light and eventually
descend into darkness when the darkness
comes Undead appear so when he considers
this everything must have become clear
when someone like vendrick considered
where the darkness must have come from
in his kingdom he would have realized
that it came to him long ago
this queen made him invade the Giants
this queen got his kingdom into the
state it was in
and this Queen came before a darkening
Kingdom when he considers this
everything makes sense his wife the
queen is a pretender and a manipulator
slowly she has grown closer to the
throne closer to the throne of want and
closer to the first flame we have no
need for two rulers nashandra 'he's want
is the first flame as it's called by the
Emerald Herald the great soul and as we
mentioned before this is either within
the structure at the end of the game or
embodied by it and so now we come to
understand the want of nashandra she
wants access to the first flame and the
great soul which is an access only a
king of drangleic can give if you
proceed nashandra will come after you
knowing that you will take the throne
and link the fire she covets the first
flame and the great soul put nashandra
to rest and n but vendrick's want was to
deny fate we see this in his actions in
the creation of the ancient dragon and
in the birth of his Emerald Herald we
saw it as he hunted the undead and we
see it within the experiments of Ali
escape and finally we see it in his soul
the soul of he who would link the
King vendrick refused to open the door
to the throne and he refused to link the
first flame with his own soul this is
the first flame that nashandra once so
badly the flame the flame Souls
nashandra is characterized by her lust
for power every fragment of her being is
bent towards this end her origins are
shrouded in mystery to the main
characters of drangleic but we learn of
her origins once we obtain her soul I
don't know if you've read it but her
soul states nashandra was born of the
dark with an insatiable lust for
strength the bow of want formed from her
soul tells us that when the old one of
the abyss was destroyed his soul split
into a miniscule fragments and these
were spread across the land the old one
is Manas from Dark Souls 1 this is
confirmed by the official guide Manas
was responsible for the spread of the
abyss in Dark Souls 1 an ancient being
characterized by his lust for his lost
pendant so similarly nashandra is driven
by her lust for power the bow of Wands
description tells us of how the smallest
of these pieces of Manas sensing its own
fragility yearned for what it lacked
precisely due to its size the smallest
piece of Manas was the first to restore
its form a form that looks remarkably
like princess dusk who Manus stole from
all the seal but that's a topic for
another day we can't be sure how
vendrick realizes this but when he
recognizes nashandra
true nature he must give up on cheating
fate he accepts that the curse will take
over his flesh and his mind but his
final act is to deny his Queen King
vendrick
prepares all the pieces of the puzzle
and makes his move whatever the cost to
him his Queen will not ascend the throne
and so let's work backwards from the
throne and let's finally see how
vendrick set up the barriers to new
Chandra's rule the Giants kinship grants
access to the throne beneath the castle
why we need to be of giant blood to
ascend the throne is a topic we'll
hopefully understand soon but note that
the throne has a human-sized seat carved
into a much larger throne we find the
Giants kinship within the memory
J a giant who fell in the final battle
with drangleic where the giant Lord was
present the giant Lord was eventually
defeated by an unnamed hero and we take
their place inside the memory in order
to obtain the Giants kinship the
memories of the Giants can only be
accessed once you have obtained the
ashen mist heart which requires the
blessing of the ancient dragon hidden
deep within the dragon shrine such a
thing cannot be taken by force mist is
associated with time travel and space
and it's also associated with the
ancient dragons so it makes a degree of
sense then that the false ancient dragon
should have the ability to give you
something like this something to access
the memory of giants something to get
the Giants kinship and something to let
you access the throne the doors to all
of these things only open when one wears
the King's ring the king resided in
drangleic castle with his queen but
eventually retreated deeper within it
with his ring I imagined vendrick
traveling with his trusted protector vel
start deeper into drung lahic
castle he assigns the looking last night
to overlook the entrance to our mana
fearing something wicked the king fled
the castle and never returned
but his warrior forever true to his
command stands ready to expunge those
who would challenge him so the king
traveled to his shrine of a mana which
exists below drangleic castle its
purpose I believe is to repel nashandra
within it are the mill finito who sing
to bring comfort to those bound by death
and dark when we sing the little one of
time the little ones grant comfort to
those who bear death and dark the little
ones are the fireflies while the mill
funny toes sing the fireflies gather
around those bound by death and dark
rendering them passive dosel and inert
if we stop them singing then the
creatures of death and dark become
aggressive and revert to the natural
selves nashandra is very being his death
and dark and she would be bound by this
calming force if she attempted to travel
through here within drangleic castle we
also see a captured mill finito which
presumably was taken by the Queen as she
attempted to penetrate the shrine after
vendrick went through it so at one point
when vendrick is traveling through the
shrine he splits himself apart from his
soul and places it behind a door only
open able by human maybe one day the
chosen undead will pass through here
unable to be broken down by the undead
curse hence they will be human and able
to open this door and obtain the Kings
soul and maybe then they'll understand
from here after splitting his soul I
imagined that vendrick is carried by his
trusted hand they'll start who carries
his husk of a body to rest in the undead
crypt they'll start known as the royal
aegis gave himself to the king both in
life and death a vendrick's armor is
placed in a neat pile with the Kings
ring ready to be taken by a worthy
Undead perhaps his gear is put aside by
they'll start in the hopes that the
chosen undead will take the ring and
what he needs but not harm the king he
has been charged with protecting the
king is a soulless husk and there is
nothing to be gained from killing him
one day this undead may link the fire
vendrick knows that he will one day be
overthrown by an undead worthy to link
the flame for it is written in fate but
he makes sure that nashandra will not be
the one to open it as the barriers to
her presence so great the Kings Ultra
great sword depicts the Queen only the
King knows whether the depiction of the
Queen is an affectionate exaltation or a
resentful mockery I believe it's the
latter a mockery of the Queen as
vendrick succeeded in delaying her
access to the throne and resentful
because he must abandon his kingdom to
keep
safe nashandra weights during all this
she guides the undead knowing she can't
hope to ascend the throne without you if
you go back to her at different points
in the game she'll tell you about the
dragon in the shrine and the king in the
crypt she encourages you to descend upon
the throne of want and waits until you
take out the throne watcher and the
throne defender before finally
presenting herself grave undead you have
proven yourself to me now be one with
the DA nashandra born of Manus has one
final chance to take out the chosen
undead and descend the throne but the
undead is strong strong enough to
overthrow the sinner the rotten the old
iron king and the Dukes dear Freya
strong enough to conquer the giant
memories and uncover vendrick and his
crypt so just like in Dark Souls 1 we're
strong enough at the end because of the
barriers in our way many of which were
put there by King vendrick and because
of vendrick we easily conquer nashandra
as she tries to stop you from ascending
the throne
hope you enjoyed these two videos guys
these two took a long time to research
and make and even then I'm nowhere near
answering all the questions in this game
there's so much left to uncover so many
things that I left out of this video
just for simplicity's sake I have a
bunch of these questions listed in the
description and I'll probably make a
video talking about them at some point
but if you wanted to try and answer some
of them with your own theories in the
comments down below that like button
then I think that would make for some
great discussion anyway click on the
bonfire if you enjoy my content and if
you'd want to Kindle the channel and
maybe I'll see you over on patreon with
this small community I have over there
but regardless of that I'll see you in
the next video later guys
great sovereign take your throne what
lies ahead only you can see
you